So for this quiz I want to see if you understand the difference between static
and dynamic typing. For each property listing below you should select which type
of language whether it's statically type language or a dynamically type language
is typically more likely to have that property. Here are the properties it
requires less code for the same amount of computation. Check whether you think
it's more likely for a statically type language to require less code, or a
dynamically type language. It's less likely for programs to crash when they are
running. It's more fun to program in. This is certainly a little subjective.
Programs should execute faster, and it would be a better choice for programming
avionics flight control software for a new fighter jet. This is a bit
subjective, and might require a little bit of speculation on your part, but I
think if you think carefully about the difference between static and dynamic
type checking, you'll be able to answer correctly, or at least get the same
answer that I will.